on va s'intéresser justement à cette
visite Emmanuelle Macron à Kiev avec
vous Bilal bonjour bonjour Alors on a vu
hier Emmanuel Macron donc à Kiev on a
l'impression qu'il semble faire des
concessions là entendu un peu sur
l'Ukraine il a aussi tenu peut-être à
afficher une certaine réconciliation
avec vos leadersky est-ce que on peut
parler de revient non pour Emmanuel
Macron ah oui on peut tout à fait parler
de revirement parce que la position
d'Emmanuel Macron était devenue
intenable le mot est n'est pas n'est pas
trop fort vis-à-vis des Ukrainiens
pourquoi parce qu'il faut savoir qu'en 4
mois de guerre Emmanuel Macron a réalisé
un exploit c'était celui de devenir
l'Allier de l'Ukraine le plus détesté
dans le pays alors pas à cause de la
politique de la France mais à cause de
ces déclarations puisque au niveau
politique la France a répondu présent
depuis le début du conflit surtout sur
l'envoi d'armes ce qui est réclamé par
les ukrainiens et on l'a entendu un peu
plus tôt dans votre journal em Macron a
annoncé l'envoi de six canons César en
plus qui n'est pas négligeable mais en
même temps et ça c'est les limites du
fameux en même temps d'Emmanuel Macron
le président a multiplié les
déclarations sur alors la nécessité de
ne pas humilier la Russie à plusieurs
reprises les peuples russes et
ukrainiens sont des peuples frères au
moment où les Ukrainiens dénonçaient un
génocide mais encore la proposition qui
est donc qui n'est donc plus d'actualité
de créer une communauté politique
européenne plutôt que de soutenir une
candidature à l'UE et toutes ces
déclarations sont venues et c'est très
important après la découverte des
massacres abucha et à irpin attribués
aux Russes ce sont des déclarations qui
ont été perçues par les Ukrainiens à
minima comme des erreurs de lecture
politique mais à maxima comme du manque
de tact voire du mépris de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron et il faut savoir
enfant que depuis le début de la guerre
les Ukrainiens emploient un verbe il
s'agit de macronés
autre soldats entre soldats ukrainien ça
signifie parler pour ne rien dire c'est
une allusion au coup de fil répété
d'Emmanuel Macron à Vladimir Poutine
mais dans le dictionnaire de l'Ukrainien
contemporain écouter bien c'est défini
comme je cite se montrer très inquiet
d'une situation s'assurer que chacun
voit à quel point vous êtes inquiet et
ne rien faire alors oui pour le
président français on le voit cette
visite à Kiev c'était un revirement
voire même une session de rattrapage
c'est une définition très intéressante
merci beaucoup